[音楽]
透明度駅バーです
保育等は大好きな8才です
アプやすいのお母さんと一緒に
nht を始めました日
エクセラー分は隅に沿ってつけるので
アイロンビーズ以来に楽しいです
を分シーの作品を上げたことで世界中の人
に貼ってくれてびっくりしました
最初は奉行んカードが買えて嬉しかった
です
でもどんどん売れることに大型になって
いき用意する家にテレビの人が来るように
なりました
そして世界的 gj
ステーばお家さんに勝ってくれた時に
ビッグにしました
彼は動くの才能とでも増えてくれました
僕は映画うわ来ないないと思ってたけどだ
全員のスタイルが書くと
1受け入れられますか
200千景作品をあげ
多くの人に買ってもらいました
僕が学んだこと3つあります
一つ0
本当の家名になって乗ったりをお金は稼ぐ
のにラッキーの大事だってこと
ドームに頑張っても成功はしません
二弾言えグラムでいることな道ラッキー
じゃないとうまくいかないことです
僕は会でしてに始まったばかりタイミング
を作品を作ることができました
二つ目早くはず梅ではライバルが少ない
ことです
大人になったらたくさんのライバルができ
ます
でもそ惑星で音が家としてやっている人も
は2から甘かったので人気になりました
3つえお金が小分けない
最初はお金が強いと思いましたでも大切ま
使っていれば小分けないことです
僕は位は稼いだお金を大学ます
そんな音に仕えその場合に勉強もします
僕は小学生にしてはリオ無謀のステージに
偉大なはセミます
神田にはスッポンこんなふうにお金を稼げ
ないかもしれません
それでもピュアファンの人に感謝して
頑張ります苔が将来にない分になるかは
わかりませんが
見守ってください
禁忌だったら可愛いなーっ
あとピン研方が実は売れてんですよ
本当に彼は
見た通りには書けないけど
その見たものを
彼の想像の中で抗議なっていって
面白い形にこうアレンジするのがすごく
上手だなあと思っています
ただどのお子さんもケット
なんか大人にはない視点を持っていたりと
か
なんか
それぞれの個性があると思うので多分この
話をしているときは目がキラキラしてると
か
この工作のこの作業をしている時は物凄い
集中してるなーみたいなことがあると思う
んですけどそういったなんかフロー状態に
なっているお子さんの瞬間を見つけて
それがきっとたぶん
かゲー
yeah が気になるかなと思うので
そういうところに注目してあげてみんな
そういう何かその表現をしていたらそれを
またインターネットとかに nft に
限ったことじゃないんですけど作品を発信
してみるって言うのは
親子にとってもすごく楽しい体験になると
思うので
ぜひ皆さんもなく発信してみてくださいと
思います
発生の方法は
そうですね本当に人によってさまざまだと
思うんですけど
ソーシャルメディアを
なんかそのように作ってメイン下に挙げる
とか
youtube に挙げるとかなんか
そんなことでもいいと思いますしこうやっ
てオープンしいって言う
マーケットプレイスで nft 化して
実際に行こう
売買を体験してもらうということも
すごいいいと思います何でもそうですね
やり方を調べれば
校
必ず見つけられるので
なんかまずはやり方を調べてみるのがいい
かなと思いますはいあとはもう失敗を恐れ
ずに
とにかくそのように出してないとやっぱり
なんかなかったことと一緒になってしまう
のかなと思っていて私自身も子供のころ
いっぱいパソコンで絵を支えていたんです
けどそれが今全部残ってないんですよね
データとして
どこかにバックアップしておけばよかった
んですけどマッスルのそういう発想がその
時はなかったんで
全部残ってなくてそれは寂しいなと思うの
でそれがブロック生肉を刻まれるという
本当にロマンチックなことだなと思います
普段から
いろんなニュースを見る見聞きするときに
これはもしかして子供間子どもの可能性を
伸ばす
何かヒントになるかなっていう視点をもっ
てみるとなんか
のすべてが教育的な機会に
感じることができるっていうのがあります
ね
からたまたま本当に nft が今黎明期
でその彼の表現と何かをつくって
物を売るという体験にすごく結びついたの
が本当に良かったなと思うのでまずはお
父さんと母さんも自分で何かやってみるの
が良いと思います私もその nft 作品
出す前に自分の作品1回出してウルって
いう経験をしていたのでただ自分が作品を
作った時はかなり考え込んでしまって
ゆっくりゆっくりをつくって完璧なのが
できたからだそうみたいなそういう感覚が
あったんですけど息子あ
結構バンバンバンバン中じゃなく発表して
言ったのでそれは凄い面白かったなという
かまあ自分が創作する上でもかなり勇気
づけられました
おやおや子さん自体がリテラシーを高く
持って
情報号
いろいろ精査するとはすごく大事なのかな
と思います
最初は a に編むん自信がないという
ことを話してたんですけどなんか世界で
作品を発信してカレーならではのゾンビず
キーパーならではの中のもチャージという
か
物事の捉え方みたいな子ところをすごく
評価していただいて彼氏にもすごく自信に
なったしそれがアーティストとしても作家
性につながっていったのかなと思います
将来
これからまあアーティストになるにしても
それ以外の職種に就くに移しても
まあここで作品をつくって自分でこう
これだけお金も稼いで世界の人がいろいろ
喜んでくれたりとかしてもう
それを貼っ最低年で体験できたのはこれ
からの将来の糧になるかなと思います
子供の頃に考えてた
ことを思い出して
なんかそれがまた大人になった時のプレー
てくな編とになればなと思います
このゾンビずきんは nst 作品の発信
が
いつまでも続くかどうかわからないんです
けど彼が楽しいって思える限りサポートし
ていきたいなと思います